el comercio no esencial en reino unido
vuelve a tener un respiro a medida que
las vacunaciones avanzan rápidamente y a
la par que las cifras de contagio
descienden el primer ministro anunció
una nueva desescalada a partir de la
próxima semana
james jones estaremos abriendo tiendas
gimnasios zoológicos campos vacacionales
servicio de cuidado personal como
peluquerías y por supuesto terrazas al
aire libre y hostelería al aire libre de
todo tipo el lunes 12 de abril yo mismo
iré al pub el cautelosamente pero
irreversiblemente llevaré una pinta de
cerveza mis laureles en gay pride vida
como el eps johnson también indicó que
el gobierno busca un sistema con el que
se pueda certificar la exposición de los
ciudadanos al virus para poder reanudar
los grandes eventos abrió también la
puerta a que los viajes internacionales
se reanuden antes de verano en grecia
donde los hospitales aún enfrentan una
fuerte presión y los casos siguen al
alza las autoridades dieron luz verde a
la reapertura de los pequeños negocios
que ahora fijos tramix hoy hablé con el
rigor y mis felizmente el mercado ha
vuelto a abrir y podemos ver cierto
movimiento espero que se mantengan las
medidas y que las personas mantendrán su
distancia con el fin de que el gobierno
no tome más medidas y no nos encierre de
nuevo vamos a llamar cuestión yo te vi
votarlo y en portugal las restricciones
impuestas en enero continúan relajándose
desde este lunes terrazas de cafeterías
y restaurantes vuelven a abrir también
lo hacen museos pequeñas tiendas y
gimnasios entre otros establecimientos
el país vivió en enero el peor aumento
de casos registrado en todo el mundo
ahora aunque los contagios se ralentizan
cines centros comerciales y otros
negocios no esenciales permanecerán
cerrados al menos dos semanas más